هنا وفي هذا المكان تحديدا ومن على كورنيش
مدينه البصره ستقام واحده من اكبر الولائم
الخاصه بجماهير خليجي 25 في مدينه البصره
اللي يضافون اخوتنا ويا مرحبا بيهم واعتقد
البصره والخليج واحد وشرف وهذه عادي يعني
وفضيعتهم ضيافه طبيعيه ويجون الاهلهم
وناسهم وهذا وين يرحون يعني غير انت
اخوتهم فاهلا وسهلا فيهم حياهم وهذا قليل
بحقهم والله كنا نتمنى نسوي اكثر بعد
جميله جدا واجمل ما فيها هو هذا الشعب
الكريم الكريم
واحده من اكبر القبائل هنا في مدينه
البصره والتي تستضيف عددا ليس بالقليل من
ضيوفي خليجي 25 من دول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي اضافه الى مشجعين المنتخب العراقي
الذين جاءوا من بقيه المحافظات العراقيه
هاي الوليمه الاولى اللي بدت من تاريخ
بطوله افتتاح بطوله كاس الخليج زين يا
اخوان الاشقاء الخليجيين وكافه محافظات
العراق زين هاي الوليمه الاولى وعندنا
اكثر من وجبه بهذا اليوم في سعه المكان
اكو ناس او ضيوف جايين دبلوماسيين زياد
الدبلوماسيه سفراء مشهده ولائم الطعام
التي يقيمها وجهه وشيوخ وعشائر مدينه
البصره باتت مشهدا مالوفا في المدينه
وتحديدا هنا من على كورنيشها الذي يقع على
شط العرب من البصره منتظر رشيد العربيه